hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Raph now you remember I
said long long ago um let me think of it
now oh yeah [ __ ] the ocean the ocean can
go die
I [ __ ] hate the ocean the ocean is
nothing but death you remember that you
remember I said that you remember I said
that you remember that yeah you're at
you guys's suggestion and at Bob's
suggestion as well
here is raft or wade and my friends my
friend suggested this to me that I play
raft and it involves my absolute worst
phobia like my 100% worse phobia Island
so anyway that is not my construction I
just loaded this up for the first time
my name is Mark EMU my name is [ __ ]
duh oh [ __ ] oh come on [ __ ] the ocean my
name is Mark hates mark mark just mark
hates just bark hates this cuz mark does
hate I don't know what the story is this
is probably a very whoa I've never
played this I've never seen this I've
never looked up a tutorial about this oh
god what happens if you go in oh god no
oh god oh god oh you can't go down which
is a nice thing oh my god that reminds
me I need to play stranded deep again I
don't know if there's been any updates
about this game but oh that's not good
oh that's oh that's not good
why is he there Oh No
Oh No okay what do I do with this stuff
that I've gotten Oh No okay so I've got
a I I understand I have to fish the
stuff out of the ocean to be able to
survive and okay so there's got to be
like a crafting menu right that's how
this stuff usually there we go okay so
building hammer ax chopped down trees
and the raft itself fishing rod I need
that I guess but I can make a building
hammer Oh instantaneous that is oh my
god Oh No let me just get this stuff
yeah bloop bloop reach reach out and
touch faith reach all right so I need to
stop being Stan you don't understand you
may think it's a joke at this point
I [ __ ] hate hi Hey with up in the
ocean I can't believe I caught that okay
but I need to stop being a little baby I
need to just get into it
whoo I'm here I got to make the most of
this I just got to do I can't I can't be
pessimistic about it I gotta I gotta
make do I'm just trying to get as much
material as possible before I need to
get going here I'm really good at this
hook as I say immediately as I miss [ __ ]
you you making fun of me up there ah
berry berry the great white Gregory
Greg Wayne Wayne Brady I'm gonna call
you Wayne Brady oh [ __ ] he didn't like
that one oh no I'm gonna call you Wayne
Brady
all right so Wayne Brady stalking me out
in the ocean there it is sorry about
thief II throw wink nail jaw or missed
ya either what is that
I want that whatever that is let me just
get these cuz I'm an opportunist okay
don't miss this I didn't miss it
this is planning
boink hey that was pretty good
hey that's pretty good okay so now that
I got that the crafting menu is tab yeah
fishing rod I don't have any rope oh boy
oh boy
chest cooking station water purifier
crop lit tree crop lot item net I guess
I guess that's good but I still don't oh
you make rope with oh oh okay so that's
good that means that I can just set this
up and be able to just have that do that
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna have
ax get uh I'm gonna get a where's
where's Wayne Brady where's Wayne Brady
alright so what I'm gonna do is I'm just
gonna start building more foundation
because I mean heck yeah oh god okay all
right oh god oh god oh man that is
amazingly scary that is astonishingly
scary trouble I can build a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I can build a spear how do I
build it what the [ __ ] Wayne Brady you
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
Wayne Brady jeez yes
Wayne what do you have to say for
yourself I've got a spear this time I
ain't gonna [ __ ] around when it comes to
my [ __ ] raft don't [ __ ] on me I'll
[ __ ] on you right back don't [ __ ]
Wayne Wayne I'm I will not hesitate to
[ __ ] you up okay so my objective is
eventually just to make one of
everything because that's what I want to
do I should have made it more lot of
totally little early so that I could
have crafted a cot more anyway empty
trash empty tin can can be filled with
saltwater that's nice make more rope ah
might as well grab the stuff that's
floating right by [ __ ] Wayne don't do
it what are you doing win a water I need
water
oh god I didn't even think about that
how do I get water water purifier this I
need this pure put salt water with this
right here
three put that
okay good it's good ready okay
then eight get some saltwater Phil Phil
okay and how do I put it how do I use
you three cook cook okay yay purify it
faster faster
this seems dangerous I'm just gonna go
ahead and say this it seems really
dangerous to just have this on a [ __ ]
boat in the middle of the ocean I mean I
know I'm desperate and all that but yeah
I should probably not do that is this
ready it pick up drinkable water put
more in there eight drink [ __ ] wind
Brady don't [ __ ] don't [ __ ] on me
don't [ __ ] on me don't sneak on me he's
gonna sneak on me okay barrel barrel
thank you okay got stuff and things and
thatch don't even [ __ ] you up awful [ __ ]
you up I will [ __ ] you up okay
I got a potato so I can cook something I
think yeah I can I can definitely do
that okay so put that it put that in
there okay four okay that's good that's
good that's good thus far I've got a
potato so I can cook that pick up
drinkable water to drink that okay fill
that cook that okay all right more yes
yes yes no didn't get that back in fact
that in fact I didn't need to throw it
all it's it's really just kind of like a
hobby of mine to throw things into the
ocean to random you know I I know it's
not important but you know I just feel
like it's good exercise for me and Wayne
Brady out here did I [ __ ] get that
potato I did it's right here okay that's
good no I think okay alright do you
think there's just a never-ending stream
of supplies but sorry the demons tried
to get out of my body but this is oddly
enough a really interesting system of
doing it like you have an ever-present
threat it really simplifies the survival
experience in a really interesting way
not in a good way that I like but you
know in an interesting one
I already have ten cans I don't need
more of those Oh perfect
glug glug okay glug glug I seem to have
a good system here I'd like another one
of these so I'm gonna do that but now
I'm gonna get another one of these gonna
put that right I'm gonna get to like a
station going boink
okay then put you in there cook you up
you up get away from me you think you
can get away from the markiplier no I
hate the ocean and so should you
looking at you did you did you yes oh
don't even think about it oh [ __ ] you up
I'll [ __ ] you up I'll [ __ ] you up I [ __ ]
yeah Wayne Brady
ha ha yeah get the [ __ ] out here Wayne
there better not be more of you as time
goes on I have a funny feeling there's
gonna be more of you as time goes on
okay drinkable water yeah that's what
I'd like to see ok so put that in
three-drug glug glug ok then this over
here
Phil Phil damn it so much [ __ ] ok I'm
just gonna put the scrap wood the wood
spear over here this here cook these up
boink boink cook my potato cook that up
that's good I don't know where I'm in
and all these potatoes from but oh the
barrels ah
Wayne Brady don't kill me don't kill me
do you I know they're coming right for
me but I just feel like it so now that
I'm not panicking let's actually take a
look at this droplet I should have a
crop lit to try to make some sort of
potato farm like that would make the
most sense to me don't you put this like
try to maximize space here it doesn't
look good I guess I shouldn't do that
because eventually I'm just gonna build
out so put that there let me try to
plant a potato okay alright okay
Oh drink drink Phil Phil okay ooh double
barrel oh [ __ ] like a double-barrel
shotgun of love yes thank you just thank
you thank you
nailed it [ __ ] gun
scrapp - okay that's good I got a palm
seed well that's interesting I don't
know how I'm gonna be able to get a palm
seed out of that but okay
oh [ __ ] you Wayne Brady so what I need
oh it's recrop 'let okay that's good a
chaste tree crop --let a fishing pole
that'd be good that's what I need I need
one of those get the Rope going more
rope I'm doing great
is there anything else I can build
that's awesome oh that's awesome
okay so whoa it doesn't make a lot of
sense in terms of selecting oh my god
okay you know what I'm just gonna make
some more pillars out this way okay so
now that I'm wider which is probably
what I needed in the first place
don't Wayne Wayne whoa I thought I saw
the tail of something big in the
distance and I did not like what I saw
oh boy okay so I don't know how harvest
do potatoes okay all right plant one
cook one plant yeah wait how many
potatoes do I have probably a lot
apparently okay so stop it stop it okay
more potatoes that's good I can just put
this in here oh it's full oh well I
guess I can cook it then I got a
drinkable water that's nice okay so I
think I've got generally a system going
on here and it's not too bad like I
gotta admit this is going pretty
smoothly I mean so long as there aren't
more sharks appearing I gotta get the
whole cast of whose line is it anyway up
in my grill but so long as that doesn't
happen I should be generally okay well
Wayne Brady's be like oh it's terrifying
don't do it Wayne Wayne Wayne think
about what you're doing okay all right
that's good good thing you thought about
that no way no I see what you're doing
no Wayne Wayne no no no means no
stranger danger
do I need to repair that or something oh
[ __ ]
well that's cool oh I want that I don't
know what I'm gonna do with that but I
want it I want to build
other floors [ __ ] is that Wayne or
is that someone else the Bernal okay I'm
gonna try to fish oh I love fishing this
thing's cool
don't know when nope
hey I got a fish I could have raw
mackerel whoa hey don't look at me like
oh [ __ ] don't look at me like that
oh you went on there real quick okay
well I mean I'm doing oddly good for
myself and maybe I could just use this
as like a platform to dive headfirst
into the mouth of the [ __ ] shark got
these dooby doo doo boo boo boo boo man
I'm gonna need more cookers that's what
I'm gonna need I need I need to put them
in a better place anyway I could put
them on her here that might be nice no
not that seven there we go good eight oh
I can't put another oh that's stupid
I could fit it right here though right
there that'd be good that's good and I
put my potatoes there
oh [ __ ] missing a lot of [ __ ] dude
okay oh oh mackerel contains a lot of
protein oh yeah okay so I'm gonna eat
this up oh [ __ ]
that's nice plant these seeds come back
here Quebec Quebec oh don't come back
there's been a lot less supplies than I
was hoping there would be and they seem
to all be drifting over that way now so
maybe I built too far over in one
direction it's kind of limiting the flow
but then again that could be a good
thing because there was there was
another material that I could have built
it was like there's this net thing used
to catch items floating by so how does
this work oh oh that's really cool
okay so then you can just walk over here
I could build out completely this way
and then I would catch everything that I
need but I don't have enough already I
need more I need to make more rope
okay I've got a lot more nets now so I'm
gonna poop that this
that's nice Boop oh man that's it that's
a sweet Boop oh that's a nice nap
all right now now Wayne do not [ __ ] up
my goddamn net I swear
also I swear that as soon as I put those
nets over there and start putting all
the other things on the wrong side it's
not my fault they just did it that way
alright so I need the drinkable water I
need to put the ropeway I need to grab
the thatch I need to grab all the
goodies the scrap I don't understand how
metals floating but I'm not gonna
question reality when I'm desperate
drink the water I need to put fill the
cast need a perm cooker and all my net
yes yes yes my sweet net hell yeah oh
that's awesome
that works great that works wonderfully
look at sweet catch bruh
okay so now that I'm doing relatively
alright I want to get more nets out
there but I'm just gonna hold off for
now I'm going to build no I'm an old off
so now that I've got enough supplies I
think I'm actually gonna start building
geez Wayne's being a bit of a [ __ ]
that's okay I'll forgive him okay so I'm
gonna build up I'm gonna build up I
don't even well I guess I didn't know
foundation over here but I'm gonna kind
of build like a hade with if that bother
you Wayne huh no no stop stop
Jesus Christ that ass alright so now
that I got what I needed I'm gonna build
the second floor because I'm very
ambitious like that so I want to build I
guess I'll need a pillar kind of a
pillar right only I'll need a pillar
yeah I think yeah I'm pretty sure then I
need a floor
well that's interesting but I don't know
what the benefit of having this is all
right this is my perch it's my lonliness
perch it's where I go to shout how
lonely I am at times just had to stop
and get this stuff before I declare my
loneliness in the world all right
everybody ready ah that's a good horizon
to look upon my kids are good good man
loneliness hey Wayne Brady all my
friends that I had hey babe I got fired
from my job I've never put money in my
pension plan I hate sharks okay all
right thanks thanks Wayne thanks for
listening to my loneliness I'm glad that
I got assembled items while I was being
incredibly lonely just you know it's a
good change of pace all right so what
else can I make what else can I make a
tree crop luyt I could put that up on my
lonliness perch well that does not fit
on my lonliness perch well this seems ah
this seems that seems too big but oh
well you know what mark a bar is not
efficient that's for damn sure if it
fits I like it all right so I'm gonna
build a palm tree barely okay it's gonna
wait a couple hours for that to finish
you up to drink but drinkable water in
the meantime could go off at drinkable
water good water drinkable it's good
drinkable and stuff anyway back up on my
loneliness birch let's see Oh what what
what direction have I not declared by
loneliness I don't think I've done it
this way yet hmm okay all right then
feeling I don't even have a beat [ __ ]
Wayne the [ __ ] was that
whoo I didn't like that I don't even
have a beach ball to be my friend I
don't even have tiny bucks to him to be
my friend thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
oh it's tiny I don't think that's how
those things grow I also don't think
that I could see them grow right before
my eyes
well that's bizarre that is just the
weirdest I don't know where I got all
this dirt from who am I to complain
about free dirt okay
build more let's build more of these bad
boys over there yeah what do you think
of that Wayne huh right
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay maybe if I build
some walls it might funnel my loneliness
ooh where did I get the cloth no
whatever can I build another one can I
build one more of those bad boys up here
please really please please fine hey
[ __ ] Wayne [ __ ] Duane god damn it
Wayne oh oh oh
I kill oh [ __ ] I killed Wayne I don't
think I was supposed to kill Wayne oh I
don't I don't think anything likes me
killing Wayne whoo something tells me
that might have been a bad idea
whoo I shouldn't have killed Wayne oh no
now that I think about a Wayne might
have been my only friend in this
horrible survival circumstance my only
friend is trying to kill me
how appropriate oh well whatever hey
yeah that's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
all right then so anyway I think that's
about the long and the short of the game
I don't know what the end goal is just
other than survival not much else to do
so I'm gonna talk this guy you know what
I'm so lonely
maybe I'm just gonna hug it out with the
bro Hey
[Laughter]
put an anti climactic end oh well anyway
so that was Raph this game is available
on it co and it's not bad there's some
potential here it's a bit too simplified
though I think it needs more elements to
it but I like the concept the concept is
interesting so long as you can make the
threats kind of incrementally get better
I feel like there needs to be a weather
system there needs to be like Crysis is
there need to be like you know other
stuff more dangerous more sharks and all
that stuff but either way it's pretty
cool so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
it down the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]